as Dawn broke just hours before Russia's
Victory Day Parade explosions sounded
over the Ukrainian capital
the windows of buildings shaking
violently from the shock waves of
missiles intercepted
there have been more attacks in recent
days and president zielinski who met
with the leader of the European union
says it's another desperate sign that
Russia's war is failing
now the number of missiles is increasing
in my opinion the Russian Federation the
military political Authority need to
sell something to their society because
they aren't achieving anything
the strikes have been going on for
months in this Square rusting Russian
armor destroyed during the first wave of
the invasion but despite the constant
attacks the resolve of this nation has
not been broken
and Ukraine is bracing itself for more
aerial attacks on its towns and cities
it's about to Stage account for
offensive after its military received
extensive supplies of Western ammunition
and equipment
many of the units will be doing the
fighting are still training for the
coming assault
and they are optimistic they can win
we are in great spirits highly motivated
and we are training we have exercises up
to four hours per day and also training
at night
but a breakthrough will not be easy
front line movement has been measured in
meters for months
an analysis of satellite imagery shows
Russia has used this time to build long
defenses across the front line
the first attack could be in the South
where Ukraine could try to break the
Russian land bridge to Crimea
it appears Russia is expecting this with
two lines of well-dug in trenches making
any advances difficult
[Applause]
but Ukraine knows success is vital
counter-offensive may be the only chance
it gets to change the dynamic on the
battlefield
and guarantee continued Western supports
Alex Rossi Sky News Kiev
what's up